welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka michael myers not
that one and in this video we're going
to be breaking down halloween kills the
long overdue movie is finally here so
sit back and trick or treat yourself to
our full spoiler review that'll be going
over the ending and what could be
happening next time there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then i highly
recommend that you check out now also
drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the video
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into halloween kills
okay so halloween 2018 was a mega reboot
for the franchise that wiped away
everything other than the first movie
from canon this included the second
halloween film which introduced the idea
that laurie was actually michael's
sister it also heavily featured the
haddenfield memorial hospital which two
shows up in this entry halloween kills
actually has several references to the
aforementioned work as not only does it
follow on immediately from the last
movie but it also shows the outcome of
the night that michael was captured this
includes an appearance by dr sam loomis
who was of course infamously played by
donald pleasence originally loomis went
out onto the lawn to find that michael
had escaped into the night but kills
changes things up so that he's there
when he was captured one of the big
issues that i had with the 2018 movie is
that we never saw how michael was caught
however this corrects that and at least
fills in the backstory of how he was
brought in we very much see things
through the eyes of a young frank
hawkins who got up close and personal
with michael after the events of
halloween 1978. michael very much gave
up and allowed himself to be taken in
but just before loomis could kill him
hawkins stayed his hand and allowed him
to live this feeling of regret
definitely hangs over the town and the
movie is very much about writing the
wrongs of the past this also works on a
meta level as it's wiping out the second
film i will discuss whether we think it
succeeds or not now michael getting
caught in the opening of the movie in
front of a house somewhat juxtaposes him
escaping the burning one that he was
trapped in during the last one and it's
sort of like poetry
it happens it happens again and it's
sort of the same thing as last time now
this idea of a fire rising is very much
laced throughout the film including the
title sequence in which we see a pumpkin
burning in the 2018 version it was a
decayed and rotten pumpkin being
restored to its former glory and that
metaphorically symbolized the franchise
being reborn here it's just flat out
carnage another film is getting very
mixed reviews i think it's definitely
something that you'll enjoy if you're a
fan of the series now another big issue
that i had with the 2018 film is that
lori's vendetta just didn't make that
much sense to me it seemed like she
dedicated her entire life to getting
ready for michael on the off chance that
he should escape she'd ruined her
relationship with her daughter and
granddaughter because michael was some
unstoppable force that wouldn't rest
until it got here i kind of felt that
with every other film being wiped out
but this lost a lot of its weight
because she'd no longer been through
what we'd seen her go through however
the movie does somewhat explain that as
it builds up michael's legend and shows
that he's very much seen amongst the
town as somewhat of a demon in the last
movie we saw how there were podcasts
books and just general sentiment amongst
the town that no one who experienced at
night ever really got over it thus it
does add some way behind why laurie is
still obsessed with michael and this
movie is very much about the survivors
of the first film banding together in
order to bring an end to the horror
there are several returning characters
from that first movie including tommy
doyle lindsay wallace marion chambers
lonnie alam and a lot more doyle is
played by anthony michael hall who
you'll probably know from 80s classics
like the breakfast club weird science
and 16 candles my favorite cameo is by
far bracket though who you will probably
remember from the first film there's a
ton of easter eggs in the film and while
the last one felt very much like the
consequences of the first movie this
entry feels like a love letter to it and
it's disregarded sequel they also do a
nod to the razer blade and candy myth
that's been somewhat of an old wives
tale for the last couple of decades and
the movie is very much about celebrating
the holiday and of course the franchise
that's tied to it the most also i didn't
realize that theo from you season 3 was
in the 2018 movie in this and shout out
to the guy for having two big things
drop on the same day now after a toast
to the survivors and laurie is thrown we
cut to the house from last time to watch
michael's escape as the fire department
unwittingly lets him out of the basement
it's an absolute bloodbath and it's
probably the best introduction in a
movie that the antagonist has ever had
as he rises out of the fire like a
phoenix from the flames and the guy has
no chill halloween halloween no chills
hey now the movie eh now the movie is
completely over the top in its score and
it's almost relentless at points due to
the horror it portrays the reason why
the first halloween struck a chord with
so many is because this was a killer
attacking people in their homes in the
suburbs it wasn't something that had
really been shown before in a film and
this movie very much feels the same way
some of the victims and killings are so
brutal and they don't cut away at all to
try and hide the horror from you a point
it's jaw-dropping and mayas is
completely thanos level in his attacks
on the citizens of haddonfield now much
like halloween too laurie is laid up in
hospital for the majority of the movie
and thus the focus of the film falls on
the citizens of the town her daughter
karen and granddaughter allison allison
and her somewhat boyfriend well not
anymore they head out to take michael
down which very much sets up the finale
the whole town goes into somewhat of a
lockdown and they hunt for michael
whilst michael hunts for them making for
a super tense film before you can say
this is for dr loomis you'll be watching
most of the characters get taken out and
there's even some slapstick kills in it
that i'm not gonna lie made me smirk a
bit come on yeah that bit was funny
wasn't it now the guy was just chilling
and barely did anything and they should
call it halloween chills eh no never
mind now it's not too long before the
town descends into chaos and the
citizens let their blind rage get in the
way of their ability to think clearly
laurie is taken out of the fight and
haddenfield itself turns into hell after
an escaped inmate is thought to be
michael the people in the hospital chase
after him and this leads to karen
escorting him through it whilst they try
to take him down unfortunately he ends
up jumping to his death and it very much
feels like mob mentality can often push
people into doing things based on very
little cancel culture turns everyone
into a monster and the film ends with
alison cameron and lonnie retracing
michael's steps as they realize he's
been taking a trip down memory lane this
ends at his house which is where it all
started and after lonnie goes into it by
himself and a gunshot is heard alison
and cameron travel in there after him
they come across the carnage that has
been unleashed on the new owners and
it's a very very scary scene lonnie is
found dead by cameron and he follows in
his footsteps which ends up leaving just
alison to square off against the shape
however just before she's killed her
mother karen arrives with a literal
pitchfork and takes his mask from him
karen leads him into a trap that mirrors
the opening of the movie in which he's
in front of his house surrounded by
people that all want to take him out
however michael de finally puts his mask
back on and though they seemingly beat
him it becomes clear that at this point
he's more than a man michael throughout
the franchise has very much taken on the
essence of evil a boogeyman that has
transcended being simply human and
instead he's very much a mirror of our
inner anger at this point he simply
can't be stopped and though it sends the
series somewhat into the supernatural
it's very much a meta comment on how
this icon is simply more than just a
character he's something big now a
million dollar franchise that's been
rebooted in retcon several times and
though some might not like this big
twist i did quite enjoy how he very much
became horror personified karen goes to
look out the window at the top of the
house and it's at this point that she's
killed by michael this very much echoes
the death of hawkins partner at the
start of the movie who stood in the same
spot before he was taken out by the
character clearly it holds a lot of
meaning as before karen entered the
house she did catch somewhat of an
apparition of michael when he was a
child i believe that this was the moment
that he caught a reflection of himself
and saw what he really was on the inside
his soul has somewhat remained there and
burned itself into the very fabric of
the house making this the center for
evil there's even some foreshadowing of
this darkness as karen does catch a
glimpse of herself at the hospital in a
reflection and everything goes black
around her this spot is symbolic for a
number of reasons as it's in front of
glass and in this dark death-ridden
location those who stand there very much
look into themselves and have to face
what they've become karen could have
returned to her daughter but instead she
stayed behind to stab michael and this
kind of sealed her fate from being the
innocent woman that she said she was she
was willing to kill just in the same way
that michael was and in the end the
anger consumed her much like how
consumed all of the townsfolk hawkins
can very much be seen as a survivor who
made it through everything because much
like laurie he didn't go to the dark
side like karen did it's said in the
film that michael is very much a mirror
of us and this is of course reflected in
the glass that someone sees when they
stand at the spot where so much death
has happened it's very fourth wall
breaking and though you don't have to
take it as meta commentary it's a very
smart way to deal with the character and
the genre as a whole the series is very
much centered around the horror trope of
a final girl and the first film in the
franchise very much helped to establish
this idea in horror lori is the ultimate
final girl and the prior movie ended
with somewhat of a trinity of final
girls defeating the horror that had
haunted them for so long however those
that have stepped into darkness can't
come out of it and thus karen ends up
falling victim to its year the movie
ends with quick cuts between lori and
michael and lets you know that from here
its own
now we already have a lot of information
about the sequel and we know that i'll
be the closing of the chapter titled
halloween ends actually kind of wish
that it would be like halloween ends
game and it would bring all the
timelines together from the multiverse
to have every version of laurie taking
down michael i don't think we'll get
that yet but one can only dream however
i believe that laurie will die in it and
then allison will end up as the final
girl laurie has already died before in
the franchise i think that it would be
very poetic for her to go in the final
movie along with michael if they are
going more supernatural with it i can
actually see the knife having some
symbolism to it and throughout this
reboot there has been a lot of attention
brought to it though it wasn't capable
of killing michael this time maybe that
in the hands of laurie it gets somewhat
of a new power that can finally end him
supernatural elements have been in the
halloween franchise before including
cults that believed michael was somewhat
of a god i think other than paul rudd
playing tommy doyle that those movies
didn't really work and to be honest i
kind of want to keep things slightly
more grounded now i might just be seeing
all the supernatural stuff here for
myself and there will be people who view
this movie and just don't see it at all
that's completely how i take it but let
me know below if you disagree as i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts on it
now david gordon green recently spoke
about halloween kills with uproxx and
during the interview he also paid some
lip service to the sequel and what will
be happening in ends interestingly he
said it will be dealing with political
issues and also the pandemic which
i don't know i don't know if this is the
right franchise to do it in saying that
though i suppose haddenfield did
somewhat go into lockdown and michael is
always masked up i think what will
likely happen is that michael will
somewhat be viewed as a plague on the
town and there will be people that use
him to push their own agendas they'll
also be more panic and so on and so
forth and yeah it is going to be
interesting to see how they close out
this rebooted trilogy now i kind of hope
it's not too heavy-handed as like i said
i'm not sure if this is the place but
we'll see how that goes as for my
thoughts on the movie as i'm sure you
can tell i did enjoy it i think that the
film does kind of suffer from being the
second part of a trilogy as it doesn't
really have a conclusive ending and at
points feels like it's setting up the
sequel rather than delivering on just
telling a good story that being said i
think it does succeed in what i believe
that a lot of sequels should do which is
to improve the film that came before it
a lot of the issues that i have with
halloween 2018 have now been rectified
and i hope that ends just the same thing
with this film there isn't really much
of a plot here and if you're not a
halloween fan i can't really see this
winning you around what it is though is
a splatterfest and i'm someone who just
enjoys over-the-top gore and giving
villains free reign so yeah i had a lot
of fun with it i also really appreciated
that opening and it's so well made and
put together that it feels like it was
raped right out of the second movie even
though it's pretty much all new footage
the movie very much carries the theme of
what fear can do to a community and it's
nice that they at least try and add some
depth to the proceedings which could be
pretty surface level however i do think
the movie feels kind of short and almost
a rush through so we can get things in
place for halloween ends which will
hopefully be a fitting finale i'm not
sure what will happen next time but i
had a lot of fun and it's definitely
better than most of the halloween
sequels that being said it's not up
there with the best ones but yeah
there's still a lot to like and because
of that reason it gets a 7.5 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film whether you agree
with the critics whether you agree with
me or whether you think that we both
suck comment below and let me know and
just to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the phase three mcu box
set on the 30th of october all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so message
me on twitter heavy spoilers if that's
you if you want emails to watch then
make sure you check our breakdown of the
batman news which will be linked on
screen right now the movie is going to
be dropping its next trailer at dc
fandom so definitely go check it out if
that hasn't already happened if you're
from the future you've already seen it
don't watch that video watch something
else and i'll see you on the next one i
mean paul you be the best and take care
of yourself good night peace